every girl needs a bestie she can count
on and that doesn't exclude Disney
Villains
in Disney's descendants Mao and Evy are
as close as can be
stay tuned to watch all the moments that
go on to prove that mal and Evie our BFF
goals when mal helped Evie in class poor
Evie when she first got to auradon she
tried so hard she really didn't believe
that she was smart of course we knew
better but in one of the funniest scenes
from the first movie Evie was really
struggling to shine in her goodness
class fairy godmother was teaching the V
Ches on how to be good she asked what
you should do with a crying baby the
answer choices were things like cursing
it locking it at a tower or carving out
its heart
Evie liked that one because it closely
resembled her mom's method of operation
the right answer was to give the baby a
bottle
Evie could not figure it out but mal had
her back she told her how to choose the
correct answer they just have to pick
the one that sounds like no fun we love
it when our BFF can help us in class
sisters mal and Evie both have some
serious family drama their moms are both
well evil Evie's mom had her convinced
that she was dumb and needed a prince
and a castle house mom just didn't love
her at all neither of them have a dad in
the picture and they are both only
children one of the sweetest scenes was
when Mao said that she never had a
sister they were sitting in their dorm
at Arden prep Evie was putting lip gloss
on mal but Evie stops her she says that
now mal does have a sister we're not
crying you're crying sometimes friends
can become family
proving that blood isn't always thicker
than water melon Evie always remind us
of that lifting each other up poor mal
and Evie they are both so awesome and so
good but their lives on the Isle of the
Lost were far from being breezy they
struggled with some low self-esteem some
days it's just hard to see the best in
yourself that's where our besties come
in mal and Evie are always lifting each
other up they always remind each other
of how great they are best friends are
important because they always see the
best in us the best friendships scene
from the first movie was at the
coronation mal is crying after defeating
her mom
she talks about being good and she looks
a TV she tells her she is so smart and
doesn't need to play dumb to get a guy
yes this scene was total friendship
goals fashion queen her mom might be the
Evil Queen but evey is the fashion queen
and she is always ready to make sure Mao
looks her best evey Han makes all of
Mao's clothes she knows her style and
she spends so much time making sure her
bestie looks amazing she's also not
afraid to make sure mal has her
priorities straight
she pulled mal away from then for her
fitting EB threatened mal and told her
that she'd be dancing in her bathrobe if
she didn't hurry hey sometimes we all
need a little tough love but it paid off
mal what's amazing at the cotillion not
all of our friends may know how to sew
clothes but who doesn't love a bestie
shopping spree who is the fashion queen
in your friendship tell us in the
comments where's my cell phone when AV
has mouths back best friends do a lot to
support us and they are really good at
sticking up for us especially when we
just can't stand up for ourselves
at the end of the first descendants
movie mal finds out that Audrey's
grandma is sleeping beauty all the mean
kids who hate the V case start being
awful and Chad goes off on them mal is
kind of stunned into silence but Evie
isn't she tells Chad that he is a huge
jerk and sprays him with her perfume
which totally knocks him out when things
go bad she keeps mal from getting into
trouble she pulls her away from the
scene mal and Evie totally balance each
other out
it's a perfect friendship boy problems
no fairy telus completes without a love
story or three Evie likes Chad at first
because he's a prince but eventually she
realizes that Doug is the only person
for her mal uses Ben at first she puts
him under a love spell
but soon she falls for him of course she
doesn't know that the spell washed off
and she's oblivious to the fact that Ben
likes her back but now decides to break
the spell she cast even though it will
hurt her goal of helping her mom she
feels guilty Evie is shocked when mal
makes the decision but she doesn't
lecture her about whether her decision
is right or wrong that was exactly what
mal needed relationship drama can get
complicated real
which is why having a best friend to
lean on is always appreciated sacrifices
Evy adjusted relatively quickly to her
new life in ours on being a VK never
stopped her from being smart and kind
so she landed a boyfriend who
appreciated her in no time
Evy becomes popular because of her mad
fashioned skills but mouths adjustment
period proved to be a lot more
challenging which led her to return to
the aisle in descendants - Evie insists
on going with Ben to bring mal back but
it's not an easy decision the aisle is a
dangerous place and our main vks are no
longer welcomed with open arms
Plus Evie runs the risk of getting stuck
on the aisle she is willing to give up
her awesome new life to help out her
bestie if that is in friendship goals we
don't know what is space between we
saved the best for last
bebe goes to mal on the aisle she
changes her mind about Arden mal would
only listen to her best friend they go
on to sing the best song ever seriously
it's one of the best songs about
friendship we've ever heard space
between hits us right in the feels every
time it makes us think of our besties
it's all about how life changes quickly
and drastically but how our
relationships with our BFFs stay the
same it talks about how our best friend
is such an important part of who we are
send this video to your besties and tell
us all about your BFF in the comments
and that's a wrap
make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up if you think maladie be our
best friend goals thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for the latest descendants news
we'll catch you next time
[Music]